well good afternoon everyone so
delighted that you're all here and it's
a great honor
to uh for yale once again to host a
discussion
with two former heads of government who
uh who have a strong connection
to this institution
tony blair as was as described to you by
linda lorimer was of course prime
minister of great britain and for three
years starting in fall 2008
taught a course here on faith and
globalization
uh and ernesto zadio who was the
president of mexico
from 1994 to 2000
joined our faculty in 2002 where he's
been 2001 2002 where he's been ever
since as the director
of the yale center for the study of
globalization
we're going to have a conversation today
on
uh aspects that
of of the global affairs that interest
them in particular
faith and globalization
issues in the middle east what's going
on in europe
climate change perhaps a few other
topics we have a number of
questions that have come up from the
floor i will try to integrate into the
course of the discussion
um
in order to keep a good conversational
flow throughout
we might start
by asking
uh prime minister to uh
to talk to us just a little bit by way
of opening about his interest in
faith and its effect on
political and social life
he launched the tony blair faith
foundation
several years ago started the course at
yale in 2008
and um
and i guess it might be interesting
since many of you
were not here for the introduction of
this uh material here at yale might be
interesting to hear you tony just sort
of explain
why you see
faith and an understanding of faith is
so fundamental to resolving issues of
conflict in the world and social social
problems of the world
thanks very much rick and first of all
can i say it's a great pleasure to be
back at yale and and to thank yale for
our partnership over these last years
that has been immensely productive and
really enjoyable um and there's one part
of that as well as running a course
which is around faith and globalization
then we have these occasional events as
well so thank you
um
the reason i i started a foundation
around
faith
and its impact on the world is that i
could see
um the two things were happening at once
the first is that
the the power of globalization and the
technology associated with it is pushing
the world ever closer together right so
people interact more than ever before
physically through migration
um online through the internet
and therefore
the types of sort of um
homogenous societies that they used to
be have been replaced by societies that
are very varied and diverse
and essentially
therefore how you understand other
people people from different cultures
nations races faiths is an important
part of understanding the world
at the same time i could see
that there was
conflict basically over half the
conflicts today in the world have got a
religious dimension to them and this is
very difficult for people to interact
with each other and
what's happening in the middle east at
the moment for example you cannot
understand unless you understand the
role of religion but if you look at the
far east
even take a country like burma where
there's now around about half a million
people being displaced in the last few
months as a result of the dispute
between the buddhist population the
muslim population and the west of the
country it's this is a global problem
which requires a whole set of different
initiatives to resolve it and that's the
reason i wanted to start
the foundation and we have our um
education part which is linking up
schools of different faiths across the
world we've got an action program and
then we started the university program
which is about studying it and
researching it here at yale we've now
got almost 20 universities worldwide in
the programme just yesterday i was in
china
in beijing where we have a partnership
with peking university even there
this issue is now
considered of fundamental importance to
understanding the country and its
development so
in
two minutes that's the reason
great um
why don't we why don't we sort of start
our little tour of the world here about
talk about some of the things that
interest that are interesting you and
involving you now
very very intensively
one of uh prime minister's
uh post-governmental responsibilities
has to has been to be the quartet
representative uh for to try to
negotiate peace in the
resolution of the israeli-palestinian
conflict
that quartet represented
represents the united nations the united
states
the european union and russia
it's been a you've been at this for uh
five six years now and five years and um
it's still a pretty dicey uh environment
with the
uh i mean let's talk maybe first about
gaza with with the um
recent
ceasefire in gaza do you think that this
is a sign of hope is there is there is
there any um i mean do do the prospects
look good for
some kind of resolution building off
that ceasefire
i think when you described it as a
somewhat dicey situation that that would
be described as an example of british
understatement exactly um
yeah no exactly i actually just come
back from my 90th visit to jerusalem
since leaving office um although as my
wife said to me it's not actually the
number of visits you make it's the
progress that counts
which
which i didn't think was remarkably
supportive i may say
the truth is we are at an impasse what
um the revel
there is a revolution sweeping the
region what happened in gaza um gives us
a respite but it doesn't alter the
long-term problem
and um what we need is for weapons to
stop coming into gaza and for gaza to be
opened up to the world again those two
things are obviously linked but you
won't have a palestinian state unless
it's the west bank and gaza together
and at the moment we don't have a an
ongoing peace negotiation so
particularly with the re-election
president obama here i think we've got
an opportunity to regrip this issue it's
essential that we do it it still remains
by the way
in my view
absolutely fundamental both to
understanding the middle east and to
resolving its problems
so sometimes people will say to you look
with what's happening in egypt and syria
and
lebanon and
all yemen and all the different
countries in the region with what's
happening there maybe the middle east
peace process is less important this is
in my view fundamentally wrong it
remains of
capital importance to the whole way the
region develops
and
if there were to be a viable peace
negotiation between the israelis and the
palestinians i think it would have a a
remarkably beneficial impact on the
whole region
it used to be said that the
israeli-palestinian conflict
helped to shore up the
autocratic regimes around the region
because it could be inflamed people
without israeli sentiment now those
regimes have fallen
but but a variant of that observation
was it used to be said that if only
israel and palestine could come to terms
in some kind of viable two-state
solution
that anti-americanism would diminish in
the region
not so clear now right
right yeah
um
the trouble is
it's you know what is actually happening
in the middle east by the way which is
fascinating to a student to politics is
that politics in the middle east is
becoming like politics everywhere
and one of the things that people used
to say to me when i was prime minister
is they say listen to the people
and i'd say
i am but they're saying different things
and the truth of it is in the middle
east right now
i think what you've got is a
long-term
struggle between
two
opposing forces
and
some people think this is a somewhat
simplistic way of looking at it but
it is
a little crude the way i'm putting it
but i basically think this is what's
going on
is that you
have got
three elements that are operating in the
region
um you have regimes that have been in
power a long time
who we like to deal with because they
provided stability except they don't
anymore
that's the first element they've got
some support by the way
but they are basically somewhat tired
and unable to deal with their situation
now secondly you've got what i would
call your
sort of
google liberal-minded elements right
these are numerous but badly organized
and then the third element are islamists
who are numerous and very well organized
and the truth is the last two groups
agree in getting rid of the first
but they don't really agree on what
comes after
and so what you've really got now as
these regimes are cast off is you've got
a struggle between
what i would call those who believe that
in the end the region's got to solve its
own problems
that the way to do that is to open up
their economy to open up their society
equality between men and women
diversity of faiths recognized and those
who believe
in creating a society actually based on
a religious view
and really based on that
supreme over every other consideration
and this struggle i think is really it's
there you can see it um in iraq you can
see it in iran you can see it
virtually in every country in the region
and i think for america the important
thing is to realize
you know it's
you know anti-american
yes there is anti-american sentiment
there but on the other hand it also
depends who you talk to which is what i
mean by saying not everyone thinks the
same so yes some people
you could go to one audience and they
would vilify america you could go to
another and they'd say i quite like some
of what they've got
um so
i think the important thing for us
is how do we support what i would call
the liberal modernizing elements within
the region and by the way one aspect of
doing that
is to try and help resolve the
israeli-palestinian question because
that is the one issue
that has i think a very
it's it's not caused um the the problems
in the region aren't caused by this
dispute don't misunderstand me but the
dispute has a kind of poisoning effect
on relationships within the region
so whereas it might have been said in
the past that the
the israeli
the lack of a solution in palestine
um
lent support to the to the military
dictatorships now it tends to it gives
the islamists an issue over the liberal
democrats yeah because people look
and one of the things that you learn
about the world today which is
fascinating
is
you've got to try and look at the wealth
through the eyes of
the
you know when you've got a dispute
trying to look at it
through the different
set of eyes so
because i'm so often in in jerusalem
then i see this dispute
the way
you know for example it's portrayed on
al jazeera and the way it would be
portrayed in the israeli media
and it's literally like the same facts
in two different
universes
so
one of the problems that you've got is
that
and this is what why you need out
outside help to shape a negotiation that
brings people together is you know if
you're a
someone living in the arab world at the
moment you've seen those pictures in
gaza of of children being killed when
the israeli strikes hit gaza
you know you're angry you're bitter
you're bitter against israel you're
angry against israel's allies
but if you're in israel
you're looking at a million people
taking shelter every night as rockets
come in from gaza and where were it not
for the iron dome
defense mechanism which takes eight out
of the ten rockets and destroys them you
you would have a lot more
deaths and killings so but you
literally when you're out there it's as
if the universe doesn't exist for the
other side right so
one of the things that is
really important today
particularly in the new media
environment with the social media which
i think is a revolutionary phenomenon
all in itself is to try and build those
bridges of understanding where people at
least even if they don't agree with the
other side understand why they're
thinking as they're thinking
you know
four years ago we talked about this and
about four years ago this week actually
in a similar forum
and you said then
every you know everybody knows the shape
of a two-state solution i mean that
actually you could write you could write
it down and everybody outside would have
would could easily come to agreement
uh and that and and yet the participants
seemed no closer to it is it so is it
you think the key
is
somehow getting them to see each other's
point of view i think the key now is to
try and
create a viable a credible negotiating
process and then back that with real
change on the ground
you know because the the the thing that
i really learned since being there and
traveling around the west bank um
occasionally into gaza
seeing obviously
the state of israel
is that
you know i don't know how whether any
people have actually ever been out to
the region but one of the things that's
really important is first of all just to
get out a map
and you see you could fit
the whole of israel and the palestinian
territory into
a bit of new york state
right so it's a small bit of territory
and basically
unless you find a way
of calming the situation and then
getting a dialogue going
then you can't
resolve it very easily and the problem
right now i think
is that there is a danger with
everything else that is happening in the
region
i think there is a danger that we from
the outside keep thinking conventionally
about this
whereas
there has literally been a revolution in
the region
so egypt
is not the same
syria is not the same in fact israel's
two major allies in the region turkey
and egypt are both
those relationships are completely
altered um the gulf countries are
you know
obviously also looking at how this
affects their own interests and then
you've got the issue of iran
so
it's quite a confusing
region yeah do you have something it's
interesting though it's interesting
well i i fully agree with the prime
minister
number one there are the elements
the technical elements to have a
solution
but more fundamentally i think there is
a question of whether people in israel
believe that the present state of
affairs
can be sustained forever
and my answer to this question is no i
mean there is no way
that you can go on like this forever so
there must be
a
a solution now
it is not so much
or only about
getting the two parts
in conflict right there
to an agreement i think this problem
needs a much
more holistic
approach
there are some
elements in the equation
that have to be put in place and just
let me give you one or two examples
one of them is iran
i don't see how
we will have a solution
if
the relationship the interaction
with iran
doesn't change
and i think you need that for two
reasons
one
you don't want to have a nuclear weapon
iran
but you don't want to have
something
a radio zone to stop that
so the only way to go is through a
diplomatic solution
with iran
and now you are not going to have that
if you don't have a a more
strategic well-defined policy towards
iran which fundamentally consists of
engagement
something that this country has really
neglected to do
for 30 or more years
so i think if the government of the
united states wanted to have
one of the pieces there they have to
deal with iran in a very fundamental
a different way than the one has been
dealt today that is one example well
there is also the question of the other
arab countries and i think there is a
new element which is uh terribly
important and i guess dan jerging has
been here spoken about that and that is
that the united states is going to be
for practical purposes
energy independent
in a few years
and i think this
can change fundamentally the way in
which
relationship with some of the gulf
countries
can be conducted
and perhaps a third example and these
are just
examples to illustrate
even domestic politics in the in the
united states you know i i consider
myself an admirer a friend of israel
so many of my friends here
are
you know the jewish persuasion and 99 of
those people
are very enlightened and they tell you
oh we need to have a solution there we
at everything that tony would say they
would say
and yet i don't know what happens
that the politics in this country
towards what's going on there
is controlled by somebody else not that
99 percent of people i talked to
in the in the in the community so i
guess that other element
if there is going to be leadership
and a holistic view has to be tackled i
think we have to be very transparent
about domestic politics in the united
states in dealing with the middle east
issues
interesting
iran do you have a view of
what the u.s and role should be should
we move closer to
europe's role
well the problem the problem that we
have
um
is that i mean as the nest has just said
absolutely rightly
you don't want a nuclear armed iran
the best way
to stop it would be if a diplomatic
solution works the problem would be if
it doesn't
um
the the the issue i mean let me let me
try and put a lot i would
what i think and i i agree with what he
was saying about a sort of holistic
solution
if i was looking at a whole strategy for
the middle east it would comprise these
elements
one where there's been revolution
support those people
that believe in democratic principles
in other words support the people who
don't just want one democratic election
one time
but want elections you know
and and realize that the true test of
the democracy is not simply how the
majority come to power but how they
treat the minority right support
um the democratic
elements where there's been a revolution
where there's not been a revolution
understand there will be unless there's
evolution so support evolution so i
personally think wherever you look in
the region there are unsustainable forms
of government
you know i mean
it can be very tricky diplomatically to
talk about this because you're sometimes
talking about close allies the truth is
there needs to be a process of evolution
we should be supporting that
thirdly we should push back on the power
of iran i'll come back to that in a
moment because the problem with the
iranians is not simply the nuclear
weapons issue it's the fact that they
are
exporting instability um terrorism
occasionally but certainly you know a
close-minded view of the world all over
the region and the fourth is the middle
east peace process i would add a fifth
actually which is dealing with this
issue of religion within the region and
how we create platforms of understanding
between faiths in order that those
people within the region understand that
there is a way in which you can have
your own faith without disregarding
someone who has a different faith okay
so i think what we need is a different
approach that puts all of these elements
together the problem is and this is
always the problem in politics that you
um you know there's a british prime
minister was once asked what is the most
difficult thing about being prime
minister and he said uh events dear boy
events
and
what actually
we have got with iran is a situation
where
probably over the next year or so
if iran continues to
ramp up its capability
and the diplomacy doesn't work we're
going to be faced with some pretty
difficult decisions
and
you know the thing is there you've got
to deal in real politics
um if israel believes that iran is
literally going to cross that threshold
i mean you can argue about what the
threshold is but if it thinks it's going
to cross it
for them it's
they regard this as existential so i
think we've got one last chance to make
diplomacy work
um i think it's important obviously that
that it does sanctions by the way are
having a huge impact i mean
iraq is now exporting more oil than iran
for the first time in
many decades the iranian economy has
suffered hugely as a result of this so
it's not as if the present policy is
having no impact
it's just we're not actually a point
where you can say it's worked so we're
in a a very uh delicate and delicate
time here and i i do believe ultimately
if there was a
a proper form of democracy in iran that
would make me 100 more optimistic about
the whole of the region overnight
so
closely connected because the efforts uh
have been in part
of repression have been supported by
iran but we have the situation
in syria as well and
you talked about the need for
supporting evolution
um and we're at a moment where
it's not exactly evolutionary it's
it's it's it's quite violent um
last week the france spain and the uk
all came out in support of the
uh
the syrian national coalition which is a
kind of loose connect coalition of
resistance forces
uh to the assad regime
is that the kind of is that a good
example of the kind of appropriate
measure and supportive evolution seems
to me it
may be that the kind of evolution may
soon be leading to armed engagement on
the part of the west yeah the the
problem that you've got is this and you
can actually see this very clearly from
iraq in fact
is that once you
once you remove
the the dictatorship and okay let's i
mean there's nothing more brutal than
the saddam dictatorship but the fact is
once you remove it out comes religious
ethnic tribal
and other
factions that then
make it very hard to stabilize the
situation
and really what you've got in syria
um
is
a very similar development in the sense
that
and let me choose my words uh
carefully since
one of the things you learn about the
modern world is that life is on the
record um
um
you see
most people are now in the situation of
saying
we want assad to go
there's got to be a new dispensation in
syria
and the hesitation western policymakers
have got
and which is why they are edging towards
intervention rather than going
wholeheartedly for it is yes but if you
get rid of a sat what then happens
and
the syrian national opposition are a
collection of different groups they've
now been welded together into something
more
more united
but even so you know if you were
to predict the future of syria over the
next 10 years you'd find it pretty hard
to do
so
the problem really is
we are faced with a situation where what
you want to do in syria is agree some
form of evolution right assad says okay
i will go but we'll have a evolutionary
process that that changes the
constitution ends up with a the people
being able to elect their government
and yet you've got at the present time
what is effectively a kind of civil war
in which by the way and this is also a
feature of this region now
you have proxies from the outside
um
inside the country proxies for outside
powers so
syria is no longer a place where it's
just a question of the
internal syrian opposition fighting the
syrian government you've got huge
amounts of outside money weapons and all
the rest of it
coming into this this this battlefield
so disentangling it is going to be very
difficult now personally i think
in the end
you know we've almost 40 000 people have
died in syria already if this continues
i think the pressure for the west to
ramp up its intervention will will
increase
but
truthfully
um if it were possible to get some sort
of international consensus that had
russia and china in agreement with the
u.s and europe that would be infinitely
preferable i i'm just not sure it is
possible but the question
is whether
we got to this bad point in which
intervention
even if it is for humanitarian reasons
and i believe in the responsibility to
protect concept the question is whether
diplomacy was given really
a good chance
and my conclusion is no i mean
look what happened with kofi annan's
work there
and why he withdrew from that
responsibility
and my reading
is simply that he felt
that the main actors were not really
interested
in getting a good diplomatic
solution
and i think that's that's pretty bad
because it's going to be very ugly right
and i think some of the parts that look
to be stubborn
well should be also i'm not talking i'm
not talking about the syrians i'm not
talking about president
assad
but even the russians the russians said
okay
what do we do well we get rid of assad
just tell me what comes next
and how is it going to work
and i think
if you don't answer those questions
it's very tough to move forward i think
the solution
has to include everybody
and this was the problem when somebody
said okay assad will be at least in a
transition
but then five minutes later somebody
said
assat cannot be there
well the whole thing fell apart and kofi
annan left
i don't know whether brakini will be
more successful but i don't see any any
progress so i i'm afraid tony is right
we are moving rather fast to something
which will be ugly
and when it happens it will be even
uglier
one more hot spot and then we'll move to
another topic but egypt
uh i mean are we going to end up in
egypt with an iran-style theocracy or
democracy or or the military come in
um well again it's very difficult to
predict i think the interesting thing
about egypt
is that
those sort of what i would call liberal
you know liberal forces are actually
you know starting to organize themselves
and as you saw when
the president was has been trying to
assume certain powers you know there's
been a pushback that's been very strong
the other thing though that is really
important in this region is to
understand the demography of it i mean
one of one of the things that
you know actually some it's kind of
embarrassing to say that i know it's
true of you as well but
i find in the five years i've left
office i've learned so much
it's a bit embarrassing really because
you think
we could have unknown all that when i
was
doing the job but
i actually remember when i was in my uh
you know because like
politics is very odd you don't
i mean my party had been an opposition
for 18 years before i came to pass so
the only job i ever had in government
was prime minister
um
and that's not a bad job no no it's not
a bad job but on the other hand you
complain i mean
you know i
i mean i wasn't complaining i was just
worried about the people really but
you know i remember about after about a
year in office where i'd be struggling
with various issues
and i said to my guys you know i think
i'd like to go out and just explain to
people you know this is my first job in
government i've been learning for the
last year they said you can't say that
come out and tell the people you're
learning on the job as being prime
minister the country will panic so
anyway we didn't do that but um
so one of the things that i think is is
really important is to understand how
some
facts that and features that you don't
think about
they don't enter the political debate a
lot but in fact are really really
important and one of the things to
understand about the region the middle
east is its demography
i mean half the population of gaza is
under the age of 18 half of it
um egyptian
egypt was a country of 30 million people
half a century ago it's 90 million today
what this means is you've got an
explosion of youth
who by the way aren't just worried about
democracy most of all they're worried
about economic opportunity
so the other thing we're going to have
to do in this region is is help them not
just with a
a process of democratic evolution they
need to take the right economic
decisions now here's something that's
very interesting um
and and
you know ernesto was the person who
really started mexico on its path of
economic reform which is why his economy
has come as far as it has today
one of the problems that you've got
is that economic
reform in these countries became
associated with the old regimes and
became discredited as a result of it and
so what's happening in egypt for example
is very often
a problem arises people come out in the
street they throw a lot more money at it
it's not actually the answer but it
seems as if that's and so one of the
things you know you say what will happen
with egypt a fundamental importance is
to understand that unless they take the
right economic decisions and again i
think we've got to help them
there is no way that the democracy in
the end will take root properly
very interesting point by the way
i just for those in the audience i i've
been trying to
i haven't asked specific questions from
the audience but your all these middle
eastern themes came up in your questions
and but here's one that came up that's a
little bit of a side track but it but it
did it does um
it responds to what you said about being
prime minister one one member of our
audience is asking
if you had a choice would you rather be
a president or prime minister
it's not a bad choice though is it
well i think it's really a question
about which system is depends on the
country
it's definitely true yeah
there are some countries that have both
i took it to mean you know
a presidential no but but it's i think
it's a very serious and profound
question you know we have been debating
that in
in latin america you know like my
country
really adopted the
the us model presidential
regime
uh and since we really came to full
democracy some years ago
a lot of people are saying you know
seriously maybe
we should go to a different system
which could be more parliamentarian and
less presidential i don't really have a
an answer a definite answer because
there are pros and cons but i think it's
it's a very legitimate
question even for countries that have a
very long tradition of presidential
systems and you're one term in mexico
isn't it yes once
six fixed term no re-election
ever and that's why i got this
great job here i've been so happy
yeah look i
i mean i think that there are advantages
and disadvantages either way i mean i
think the
the advantage of the
well obviously in the uk we we couldn't
have a president because we got the
queen so
just want to make that clear in case
there's any
any burgeoning republican sentiment in
the crowd here um
but
it's
i i actually think the real issue is
this
the single most difficult thing i have
found in politics is making effective
change
and therefore the thing whether you're a
president or a prime minister the thing
that i
now like to sort of think about study
and talk about and
interact with different presidents or
prime ministers is the single toughest
thing in politics today
is actually getting things done
you know i used to think when i first
came to office
you know my party labor party had always
been taught that the the civil service
and the system was a kind of conspiracy
of the right wing and so on and so forth
and after a few years i began to wish it
was a conspiracy to do anything
because really what it was it was a
conspiracy for inertia and
what you find is the most difficult
thing today
is trying to make change in
circumstances where the short-term
politics is often very tough where the
vested interests are very strong pushing
back against the change whether you're a
president or a prime minister the
hardest task and it's something that you
know i often say to people that the
journey of being a leader
is that you start at your
least capable and most popular
and you end
at your most capable and least popular
right at least that was my journey but
and so
you know what happens is by the e
people forget that the process of
governing is also itself
a discipline
something that you need to learn and you
need to be be creative and innovative
about and it's tough
you know your question is so serious
that can be given an example to respond
you had a parliamentarian system here
right now we wouldn't be talking about
the fiscal cliff that's right because
the government was already in power and
they have to decide whatever they need
to decide
to save the situation
and here we are you know every day
afraid of what will happen and this is
true but you have a you have different
pathologies no i'm not arguing in favor
of civil service that's the resistance
as opposed to a legislation and also by
the way your own
you know parliament you can have i mean
we've got a coalition government in the
uk now and some of those decisions can
be difficult to do but you know there
are advantages and disadvantage i think
between the presidential prime minister
or system personally one thing i think
is great about your presidential system
is that you can choose people from
outside parliament to be in your cabinet
whereas in the uk system you basically
choose
from within the ranks or you make them
lords and put them in the cabinet
there are there aren't enough rotten
boroughs anymore we did occasionally no
i we did occasionally
mark malok brown was working with the
center and one day i'm going to the
british garden that made me lord and
went to the cabin
we're going to have that's
dirty linen aired from both hemispheres
it was a good trick unfortunately it was
one you couldn't play that often but
anyway yeah yeah moving right on yes
okay a different topic
um
a lot of audience interest in the sort
of obvious question
um
let me put it provocatively is the
crisis of the euro over
you want to tackle that mr economist
first
well now we are really going into very
depressing topics oh yeah
no
no no i i am still terribly
worried and concerned
president
and let me start
perhaps
a little bit from the end and backwards
i think that if the
euro
zone breaks down collapses
that is going to be the beginning of the
collapse
of the single market
and eventually could be the collapse of
the european union
all of that bad enough for europe
and if all of that happens
i think
also horrible things
will happen in the rest of the world
i think that could be the beginning
of the end of our
contemporary globalization
will be such an economic disaster
we will see
within a few years going into trade
encouraging words
and we will really see a dramatic
process of disintegration
i am
you know absolutely convinced
that that is the case you don't think
that things are
a little bit safer that those things are
less likely
well i would say
not so much i mean the only
significant thing that has happened over
the last few months only one
you know that was mario draghi's
statement
that the european central bank will be
willing to do these government bond
operations
now but that is not enough because
markets at some point well we realized
number one
that the country to which that was
offered which was
spain immediately started to be
reluctant to say when how and where
they will do the package that would
allow them to be in the position to have
their paper bought by the by the ecb
so that's just one example
and there is
this whole story over three years
of how the europeans
have always been behind the curve
only in the last moment they have been
able to do something to prevent the
collapse
and i don't think you can be playing
that game
for too long it's extremely risky
right now as we speak
the europe is in recession i mean the
the continental economies are in
recession
the political and social condition is
deteriorating so quickly i mean
i i happen to read el pais the spanish
newspaper
every day because it's a very good
global newspaper and it's just striking
how bad the social and political
conditions even the risk of
fragmentation of spain is now being
entertained i mean that has been always
there but this economic crisis
has been a catalyzer for this catalonia
basque and so on
separatism
so my fear is that one of these days you
know they will have a bank run
and then it will be very hard to react
and too late to react i mean technically
the answer is very simple you want to
have
a monetary union you have to put other
ingredients into the soup
you need fiscal union or fiscal strong
fiscal
coordination you need to have an
explicit well-defined
well-institutionalized lender of last
resort
to do disa i mean now we know nationally
there is ecb but that is not formal
eventually you have to have a banking
union and i would say
in a few decades you really believe in
the european project which i think is so
important for europe and for the world
well you have to have something that
approaches the united states of europe
but none of the crucial elements are
really being
implemented
in a solid
you know strategic way there are things
here and there and i am afraid that the
risk of having a disaster is still
considerably higher
your uh uk of course isn't in the euro
zone but it has you have been a strong
advocate for
political integration and you're in uk
being deeply involved in the politics of
europe
where do you see it well
i think ernesto's analysis is basically
right look the the the problem that
you've got with the single currency
and it's a very interesting
uh lesson in politics actually
the single currency um
was an idea motivated by politics but
expressed in economics and that that's
its problem
so
basically what happened was when we
created the single currency zone i
actually remember
um
a dinner that we had this was just
before the single currency came into
effect i just become
a prime minister we weren't joining
ourselves but we were having a debate
about the way the single currency began
and basically one group of leaders
sitting around the table said look maybe
it's better we start the single currency
with a core group and then we add people
as their economies come into line
right
and that was then rejected by others who
said no it is
vital for the political integration of
europe that anyone who wants to come in
can come in
and the problem then if you take
italy for example when italy came into
the single currency
italy's interest rates dropped i don't
know seven eight
points
right now that wasn't because
of something that they'd done to their
economy was because they'd essentially
joined the german
currency zone
so what then had to happen was that
italy then had to engage in a huge
process of adjustment
to make the economics align with the
politics
and it didn't happen
so
you know it's taken us 10 years to
realize that italy is not like germany
well
okay
and the difficulty now is this and this
is the point that ernesto is making
really is that normally what would
happen if you're faced with a huge debt
problem like this
is that what you would do is you you
would devalue your currency
you would grow and you would make
structural reform the problem is within
inside the single currency zone you
can't do that
right
so
you're absolutely right rick that the
the um
the actions of the european central bank
has eased the liquidity problem but they
haven't that on its own cannot deal with
the two other issues which are the
solvency question
um particularly in relation to the
banking system and the growth question
because if you don't get growth then
it's very hard economy yeah so
my view is we are right you know the
edge of this at the moment i mean i hope
for the reasons that have just been
being given by the president i hope that
we can come
through this
um the stakes are immensely high but i
personally think the only thing that
works is short term what i would call a
kind of grand bargain in which germany
stands behind the single currency
completely and the measures that are
necessary are taken and then long term
frankly europe's got to reform its
social systems and it's got to reform
them by the way for long-term reasons
that of the same reason you in the u.s
have got to do a certain amount of
reform um why we in the uk have to and
again
reasons like demography in in the 1980s
the average age of the european
population was early 30s today it's
early 40s you know technology
the way the states develop all of these
things
create the need for change so
i think
on for europe right now
um
no we're not out of the woods there's
there is a renewed political will
but it's still
immensely fragile and the stakes we're
playing for in the world economy are
very very high
well uh i would just take exception to
one thing which is the the
one way to look at it is the the states
that seem fiscally irresponsible
responsible need to reform
another way to look at it is if you look
at an integrated currency area like the
united kingdom or the united states
you have rich regions and poor regions
and by having a fiscal authority the
rich regions subsidize the poor regions
so
we don't ask mississippi to get its
house in order
we basically transfer
uh we basically transfer funds there and
poor labor mobility and labor mobility
most people above that yeah so it's a
little it's a little i mean you i think
i agree with ernest you need a fiscal
you ultimately need to have
integrative fiscal right but the moment
you do that you will find there is
enormous pressure for political
institutions that's right that reflect
that that's right is also very very
tough yeah so anyway
i always say to people whenever i'm
talking the world first of all we talk
about the middle east and then we talk
about europe and then everyone gets
really depressed so i say let's talk
about africa because i'm optimistic
about africa okay
it's been growing it's been a bright
spot in the world economy last five
seven years that's true
um
there
not a lot of hope um
i know one of your other passions
another another one another area where
you have uh worked hard these last few
years for
global understanding is the climate
change area and and that's
um
at least with the re-election of
president obama
um
the the fact that we actually have made
some substantial gains in carbon
reduction due to the slow growth of the
economy in part also in part to the
abundant
natural gas findings and the price of
points
and and and finally for regular you know
major regulatory actions taken in the
united states and china don't often get
noticed but we have actually cut carbon
missions united states nine percent in
the last five years
um
so the question is is
are there you know is there are there
some prospects for some progress on that
on that front in the years immediately
ahead i think i mean first of all by the
way in energy terms what you're talking
about and shale particularly that's a
game changer the whole of the american
economy and for the i think it's got
massive implications for geopolitics i
agree um
and they're also by the way substantial
reserves of shale and china as well
which is going to make a um a difference
and
i think on the climate issue
look
it's it remains incredibly important i
mean i i find it completely absurd when
people say well as a result of the
economic
downturn you know we should not
care about the climate issue if it's if
it's right to care about it you should
be caring about it irrespective of the
state of the economy because long term
of the damage that it's going is going
to be done to the environment and i look
there's still a residual scientific
debate about climate change but even on
a basic precautionary principle there is
sufficient scientific weight and
evidence behind the fact that that there
is a serious problem you know for us to
deal with it so we should
the difference i think the in approach
that i would take
is that i think trying to get this
agreement
you know done between all the countries
of the world and this process that's
going on in doha in qatar at the moment
i think it's terribly difficult to do
personally i would take the obligations
countries have entered into already i
put them together i would get the thing
moving
and really look at how you incentivize
the development of the science and
technology in these areas because that
is the only way ultimately you're going
to resolve this i mean you know
as i say i was in china yesterday
you know china's economy is going to
carry on growing they've still got to
lift hundreds of millions of people from
subsistence farming into industrialized
economy then
they're going to carry on consuming so
we either find ways of doing it
sustainably or we've got a big problem
and that's where i would put the
um the the emphasis and and yes i think
the
re-election of president obama here
gives us an opportunity but you know
frankly he needs
the cooperation of the europeans the
chinese the indians and the emerging
market economies
have any of you
well
again
i think this meeting in doha
is going to lead nowhere
i don't see any possibility
of any breakthrough
i am afraid that
some of the premises on which we have
been working all these years
will lead will continue to lead us
nowhere
and
as long as we don't recognize
that
measures have to be more aggressive
in terms of pricing on pricing carbon
uh we are not going to have
really significant progress
there the controversy comes because
there are basically two schools of
thought
one who was the winning side some years
ago with this cap and trade
approach
and the other people who believe you
know that direct pricing
will be the way to go
some people predicted that the cap and
trade will fail
uh
simply because you converted the problem
into a zero sum game
your emissions
are not my emissions and vice versa so
that has really no geopolitical solution
so some of us said no the commitment
should have been
about pricing carbon
and not even sharing the revenues of
your carbon pricing because if you move
into that and try to make an
international transfer mechanism it
again will be geopolitically extremely
complicated
you mentioned the case of the united
states i mean and i think the most
important factor has been
that the price of oil has been
consistently high now for almost 10
years
and that has induced changes in economic
behavior and by the way that caused this
boom in shale gas i mean we have known
of jail gas for many years
uh we have known the technology which is
not a big deal
but the price was not right to do it now
is right and we are seeing this energy
revolution in the united states so if we
only took this experience
to
apply the very elementary symbols
and put that into an international
agreement that has to be fundamentally
different from the kyoto protocol then
there will be
some promise but if we continue to patch
and to
make a list of good wishes and goodwill
and i don't think we are going to go
nowhere and this is a disaster because
this is happening and will continue to
happen and we will regret it well my
children and my grandchildren will
regret that we saw that we were so
incompetent for not having done
something serious yep
so
when we had we had a conversation like
this four years ago exactly this week
uh right after president obama had been
elected to his first term in office
the question i asked you to close that
session was what advice do you have
for president obama as he enters his
first term so let me ask the question
what what advice would both of you have
for president obama entering a second
term
what would you do if you were he i think
i remember saying that i wouldn't
presume to give him advice
i know i'm not letting you off the hook
this time
i think
actually by the way you've said that and
then proceeded to
that's because i'm a politician
yeah i i think the single most important
thing right right now is that
actually the world at the present time
uh needs america's leadership
um
the world is a a it is going to develop
in a multi-polar way today so it
requires a different type of leadership
but i think whether on the global
economy or in the issue of climate or
international security um
my view is that the the the single the
single most important thing that people
from the outside want to see about
america is to recover its economic
strength
um to stand up for the values that we
believe in and hold dear because they're
basically good values that most of the
world shares and one other thing that i
think is really really important you
know the thing that i have learned
seeing
different people in different parts of
the world
is that ultimately here is the good news
amongst all the gloom wherever you go
what most people want
is the same
they want to be able to
bring up their family with a certain
amount of security to have their
children do better than they did or at
least of the opportunity of doing so and
to live in a society where the
government is underneath you rather than
on top of you right that is what most
people in the world want wherever you go
and at its best not always
it doesn't always done it but at its
best
that is actually what america represents
and the world needs american leadership
you should be proud of the leadership
you give you will be criticized for it i
always say this to people in america
give up on being loved that's not your
role in life okay
your role in life
is to represent what at your best you
can be and give that leadership to the
world because the world is better off
for it
very good advice
well i i never give advice
express good wishes and i wish that
president obama
you know works hard on the economic
issues
i think this country has
incredible potential
because of all its flexibilities it's
relatively young population its natural
resources and if the u.s economy does
well it's
educated it's superior universities too
right yeah
i don't want to inflate your ego too
much
so
but anyways i think that if the u.s
economy does well
in a sustained
manner i think that will mean a lot for
the global economy certainly for my own
country
we are now so interdependent fortunately
with the united states so we need the
u.s to do well others need the u.s to do
well but as the prime minister said the
u.s has to have leadership but you don't
get leadership by saying nice things
you get leadership by doing
the right things and i think
a first big test of this new stage for
president obama
is
how this
fiscal cliff which actually is a much
broader topic
i mean this is really defining
how
the united states is going to adapt
adjust
itself to
a particular period over the last decade
but more importantly looking forward in
my view as a former politician
i think right now he has a great
opportunity
but
he has to have a plan
a very comprehensive plan
and he has to be willing to swallow
a lot of
discomfort within the next few weeks and
months i remember when i was in office
you know president clinton had this
difference with mr gingrich
and he allowed the government to be shut
down
it was terrible horrible for a few days
but eventually you know he did extremely
well
and he
even became very popular again
so i think president obama this is his
moment and i don't think he should
accept just some mending
things to to
to kick the can
down the road this is the moment of
truth to give this country a viable
sustainable program to recover its
economic bigger and he can do it yeah
and i think he's absolutely right and i
think president obama's got the the will
and determination to do that just before
we end by the way i tell you one great
story about
president sedillo
i remember him telling me which is that
when he was in office
he knew he was doing the right thing
because he was having to take some very
unpopular decisions he knew he was doing
the right thing
when his opinion poll rating fell below
the rate of inflation absolutely
it's a great test to apply to a
politician
let's hope we don't have to go that far
this time in a low infant inflation
regime thank you both very much
you